dans le cadre du Scaff l'ambition c'est
que les avions européens travaillent
entre eux mais comme la majorité des
avions européens sont américains
la majorité des avions européens sont
américains d'origine américaine je
répète pour
l'éducation de des populations et le
la problématique se pose c'est un vrai
sujet je sais pas y répondre moi quand
dans ma jeunesse quand je suis rentré
chez Dassault je travaillais dans les
groupes d'interopérabilité à Bruxelles
au sein de l'OTAN pour dire voilà nous
français c'était une bagarre permanente
très dur avec nos amis américains mais
on arrivait à imposer quand même le fait
que si vous voulez qu'on soit vos alliés
il faut quand même ouvrir votre
capacités à l'interopérabilité ce qui se
faisait à l'époque ça s'est perdu je
pense qu'il faudra y revenir et c'est un
des grands sujets
du futur
c'est pour ça que mettre plus de pays
F35 dans le Scaff je vois pas bien le je
vois pas bien le sujet moi mais bon
c'est c'est mon côté un peu restrictif
donc je peux tout de suite traiter cette
problématique
pourquoi est-ce que je ferai de la place
à mes usines à mon bureau d'études à des
gens qui ont fait le choix du F35 à des
sociétés que j'ai vu agir derrière leur
gouvernement pour acheter du F35 donc je
vais enlever de l'emploi de France pour
aller le mettre dans des pays qui ont
fait le choix d'acheter de la capacité
du F35 sur le thème de dire ah mais oui
mais grâce à ça demain j'achèterai
européen oui c'est il y a que ceux qui
le disent qu'ils peuvent le croire quand
même j'espère que personne n'est dupe du
fait que c'est pas parce qu'on fait une
coopération technologique que demain on
va pas acheter américain alors ça ça
renvoie la problématique de l'Europe de
la défense qui est un autre sujet qui
est le sujet est-ce que l'Europe
s'organise pour etc etc on irait tous
favorables à ça mais ça prend quand même
un peu de temps et en attendant et je
pense qu'il mieux vauteux il faut tenir
donc je suis voilà on a trois pays qui
n'ont pas acheté du F-35 sauf que depuis
qu'on a démarré le Scaff l'Allemagne l'a
fait elle qu'elle l'a fait uniquement
parce que je rappelle ça aussi c'est
l'art de la répétition elle est obligée
par les Américains pour être capable de
tirer une un armement nucléaire
américain
à la main du président américain
d'acheter des 35 pour mener cette
mission et bien entendu est-ce que je
dis publique il y a rien de il y a rien
de secret bon je suis pas sûr que ça
soit le concept français je suis même
sûr du contraire
ok ça ça ne gêne pas de faire une
coopération dans ce contexte là
puisqu'on a parlé de des problématiques
franco-allemande et les Espagnols pour
l'instant n'ont pas acheté de de
F-35 je rappelle qu'ils ont quand même
des 18 et 15 jours ou l'autre faudra
remplacer les 18 donc si dans la
coopération de demain jusqu'à CAF on a
plus de pays pro F35 que de pays pro
indépendance ça peut poser question sur
la ce que vous avez dit mais ce n'est
pas mon sujet c'est le sujet de l'état
et c'est à l'État à l'évaluer je suis
sûr que vous avez vos votre opinion sur
le sujet et vous devrez le l'exprimer
moi je défends simplement le fait que
j'ai déjà accepté un tiers du travail
par rapport à trois tiers
il est en France les deux autres tiers
ne sont pas en France bon je pense qu'il
est quand même intéressant de de
continuer à poursuivre le fait de
développer vous avez parlé de l'export
si vous prenez le Rafale on est grosso
modo à plus d'export que d'avions
français enfin disons que pour
caricaturer on est à 55 ans ça veut dire
que j'avais 100% et c'est doublé par le
fait que et le travail vient en France
les
usines dont on parle les cadences 3
c'est en France ça fait travailler
Seclin Mérignac Biarritz
Argonay dans voilà un petit peu tous les
territoires et ça c'est que Dassault et
derrière pareil avec nos amis de
safrante Thalès et les fameuses 400
entreprises on peut aussi penser que
demain comme il y aura plus d'Européens
qui achèteront des avions
on continuera à exporter parce que tous
les Européens sont prêts à exporter ça
fera encore plus de volume et donc le le
tiers ou moins du tiers nous rapportera
autant que ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on
peut le penser on peut le croire moi
j'aimais des réserves sur le fait que ça
soit aussi simple que ça voilà donc je
suis pas très pour répondre aux
questions l'élargissement rapide c'est
déjà difficile aujourd'hui je répète ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure on fait la
phase 1 B on obtient un contrat phase 2
avec les mêmes parce que sinon on
réouvrira tout le partage des tâches on
a bien les Espagnols pour un tiers
Indra et sont des gens à qui on a
beaucoup travaillé ils sont un peu
écrasés par Airbus en Espagne
bon ça peut nous arriver d'être écrasé
aussi par Airbus en France mais Dassault
c'est à peu près se défendre
mais ce sont des partenaires fiables on
a fait le neurone avec eux ils ont fait
leur boulot moi je suis très content
d'avoir les Espagnols
je suis aussi très content d'avoir les
Allemands il y a pas de problème parce
que pourvu qu'on se qu'on se mette
d'accord et que les négociations
aboutissent voilà donc pour l'instant
c'est plus un problème de négociation
c'est un problème de faire le travail si
on rouvre la porte trop vite
j'entends dire on pourrait donner du
travail aux sociétés belges tout de
suite non moi je suis si on m'impose je
me battrai mais je vois pas pourquoi je
donnerai du travail au Belge aujourd'hui
[Musique]